What we're going to do in this
video is, through a bunch of
examples, familiarize
ourselves with the
x,y-coordinate plane.
And first we're going to just
look at some points that are
already plotted and figure
out their coordinates.
Then we're going to look at some
coordinates and figure
out where those points are.
Then we'll do one
more problem.
So let's figure out
what are the
coordinates of these points?
So you have this point
right here, A.
So its x-coordinate, you
can see it right there.
You just drop down.
Where does it intersect
the x-axis?
x is equal to 5.
So it's the point 5 comma and
y is going to be equal to 6.
5 comma 6.
Now this point B here, what's
the x-coordinate?
It is 5 to the left.
5 to the left of the x-axis.
This is negative 5.
Its x-coordinate
is negative 5.
y-coordinate is, if you just
go straight to the right,
you're going to hit
y is equal to 5.
y is equal 5.
Let me switch colors.
C.
I think you're getting
the hang of this.
Let's do the y-coordinate first.
The y-coordinate is 3.
You see that right there.
And then the x-coordinate
is negative 2.
Negative 2.
You always put the x-coordinate
first. That's
just the convention we use.
D, x-coordinate negative 2.
You see that right there.
y-coordinate negative
2, as well.
Let me get another color.
E, let's do the y-coordinate.
We'll figure it out first,
but you always
have to write it second.
It's negative 4.
You see that right there,
the y-coordinate.
The x-coordinate is 3.
And then finally, F.
The x-coordinate is 2.
And the y-coordinate
is negative 6.
Hopefully that gives you a sense
of at least figuring out
the coordinates.
Now let's go the other way.
Let's start with coordinates
and figure out where those
points are.
So you have this first one.
I'll do it lowercase case a in
parentheses to differentiate
it from this uppercase A.
So it's at 4 comma 2.
x is equal to 4.
y is equal to 2.
So that's that point
right there.
Let's do the next one.
Let me do it in a color that
you'll be able to read.
b.
x is equal to negative 3.
y is equal to 5.5.
So you go all the
way up to 5.5.
y is equal to 5.5.
So that is the point lowercase
b with parentheses around it.
Then c, 4 negative 4.
x is equal to 4.
y is equal to negative 4.
Right over there.
And then one last one.
I'll do it in orange.
d, x is negative 2,
y is negative 3.
Right there.
That's the d with parentheses.
And you could have gone
the other way.
You could have said, hey, y
is equal to negative 3.
x is equal to negative 2.
So you could go to the
left and down.
Or you could go down
and to the left.
And you're still going to
get to the same point.
So hopefully that gives you a
good sense of how to figure
out coordinates.
Or if you're given coordinates,
how to figure out
where to plot something on
the x,y-coordinate plane.
Now let's do a slightly
more involved problem.
So it says the following 3
points are 3 vertices of
square A, B, C, D.
Plot them on a graph.
Then determine what the
coordinates of the fourth
point, D, would be.
All right, let's plot
these on a graph, as
they tell us to do.
All right.
That'll be my y-axis.
That's my y-axis.
The vertical axis.
That'll be my x-axis.
And let me put some--
let me mark it.
So that's x equals 1, 2, 3, 4.
This is x is equal to negative
1, negative 2, negative 3,
negative 4.
That's y is equal
to 1, 2, 3, 4.
This is y is equal to negative
1, negative 2, negative 3,
negative 4.
I could write that
this y equals 4.
This y equals negative
4. x is equal to 4.
x is equal to negative 4.
And let's see.
Let's plot these points.
So first, we have the point
A is equal to negative 4,
negative 4.
So we go x is negative 4.
And then y is negative 4.
So we drop down 4 right there.
And that is our point A.
Negative 4, negative 4.
And just to familiarize yourself
with a labeling
scheme that you may or may not
have seen before, is that
people label these sections
of the coordinate plane.
They call this the
first quadrant.
second quadrant.
They call this the
third quadrant.
And they call this the
fourth quadrant.
And these are just the Roman
numerals for I, II, III, and
IV, So this point is in
the third quadrant.
When we looked up at this stuff
over here, these points
are in the fourth quadrant.
These are in the third,
second, first. Just an
interesting thing to know.
Sometimes someone might
ask you, what quadrant
is that point in?
And you just say, OK, I see.
If they're both negative,
they're going to be in the
third quadrant.
If just the y is negative, but
the x is positive, you're
going to be in the fourth.
If they're both positive, you're
in the first. If y is
positive, but x is negative,
you're in the second.
And we'll talk a little
bit about that as
we plot these points.
So point B, x is positive.
It's 1, 2, 3.
And y is negative 4.
So we drop down here into
the fourth quadrant.
That is the point B.
It's 3, negative 4.
So we can already see the bottom
of our rectangle that
they're talking about,
right there.
And notice, both of these
have the exact same y.
They're both at the same
level below the x-axis.
And then what's the
next point?
Point C is 3 comma 3.
So 3 comma 3.
It's in the first quadrant.
Both of its coordinates
are positive.
3 comma 3.
Both x and y are positive.
And notice, it's on the
same vertical as B.
It has the same x value.
They both have an
x value of 3.
So it's right above it.
Right above it.
Now we have to figure out
the last point here.
Well, the point is going to
have to be on the same
vertical as this point.
It's going to have to be on
the same vertical as this
point, which means it's going
to have the same x value as
this point.
So its x value is going
to be negative 4.
And then it's going to have to
be on the same horizontal as
this point.
It's going to have
to be on the same
horizontal as that point.
So it's going to have to have
the same y value at the same
height above the x-axis.
So it's going to have to be 3.
So that is our point D.
Notice it's at negative
4, right above A.
And it's at y is equal to 3.
Right to the left of point C.
And we are done.